>>> STEVE BANNON AEARING IN
FEDERAL COURT AFTER SURRENDERING
TO AUTHORITIES.
TRUMP WAS CHARGED WITHONTEMPT T
OF CONGRESS AFTER REFUSING TO
COMPLY WITH SUBPOENAS FROM THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
BANNON EMERGED FROM THE
COURTROOM DEFIANT.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
MISDEMEANOR FROM HELL FOR
MERRICK GARLAND, NANCY PELOSI
AND JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN ORDERED MERRICK
GARLAND TO PROSECUTE ME FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE LAWN WHEN HE GOT OFF
MARINE ONE.
WE'RE GOING TO DO -- WE'RE GOING
TO GO ON THE OFFENSE.
IF THE ADMINISTRATIVE STATE
WANTS TO TAKE ME ON, BRING IT.
>> JOINING US NOW IS THE MAN WHO
YOU SAW STANDING NEXT TO STEVE
BANNON THERE, HIS ATTORNEY DAVID
SHONE, ONE OF FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP'S IMPEACHMENT
LAWYERS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US THIS
MORNING.
I KNOW YOU SAY YOUR CLIENT HAS
TO WITHHOLD DOCUMENTS AND
TESTIMONY BECAUSE PRIVILEGE HAS
BEEN INVOKED.
BUT IT HASN'T.
SO WHY ARE YOU SAYING THAT?
>> LET ME PREFACE MY COMMENTS BY
ONE THING --
>> BUT IT HASN'T.
>> I DON'T WANT TO SIT BEFORE
YOU AND BEAT YOU UP.
I DON'T WATCH TELEVISION MUCH
BUT I KNOW YOU HAVE A
ACCOMPLISHED BACKGROUND,
PROFESSIONALLY AND PERSONALLY.
I WANTED TO COMPLIMENT YOU ON
THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU MEAN.
MR. BANNON'S LAWYER RECEIVED A
LETTER ON BEHALF OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, INVOKING THE
PRIVILEGE, DIRECTING HIM NOT TO
APPEAR, DIRECTING HIM NOT TO
TURN OVER DOCUMENTS, THAT'S HOW
PRIVILEGE IS INVOKED.
AND AS A LAY PERSON, ONCE
PRIVILEGE IS INVOKED, IN MY
VIEW, BASED ON THE ADVICE HE GOT
FROM HIS LAWYER, MR. BANNON HAD
NO CHOICE.
IF HE WERE TO JUST TURN OVER THE
DOCUMENTS AND SHOW UP FOR THE
DEPOSITION, THEN THE GENIE IS
OUT OF THE BOTTLE, CAN'T BE PUT
BACK IN.
HIS LAWYER REQUESTED THAT IF HE
WERE TO SHOW UP, THAT A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PRIVILEGE
HOLDER, THE REPORTED PRIVILEGE
HOLDER BE PRESENT TO INVOKE
PRIVILEGE ON A QUESTION BY
QUESTION BASIS.
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE REFUSED
THAT.
LET ME SAY THIS ALSO -- I
ORDINARILY DON'T COMMENT ON A --
>> THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO CLEAR
UP, THOUGH.
>> SURE.
>> FORMERLY TRUMP HAS NEVER
INVOKED EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
YOU'RE SAYING HE SENT A LETTER
TO THE FORMER ATTORNEY FOR
BANNON, BUT HE HAS NOT ACTUALLY
INVOKED FORMALLY EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE WITH THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
>> FRANKLY WITH ALL DUE RESPECT,
I DISAGREE WITH YOU.
THIS IS HOW PRIVILEGE IS
INVOKED.
PRIVILEGE HOLDER IDENTIFIES AND
COMMUNICATES WITH THE PERSON WHO
HAS BEEN DIRECTED TO PROVIDE
WHAT HE BELIEVES TO BE HIS
PRIVILEGED INFORMATION, AND THAT
PERSON ACTS ACCORDINGLY.
AND, BY THE WAY, THE WAY THIS
IS -- I WANT TO SAY THIS, I
THINK FOR MY DUTY OF THE COURT,
I ORDINARILY DON'T COMMENT ON
PENDING CASES.
IN THIS CASE, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DECIDED TO PUT OUT A
PRESS RELEASE SAYING THIS CASE
REFLECTS THE PRINCIPLES OF EQUAL
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
IT ABSOLUTELY DOES NOT.
I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE THAT SINCE
2008, FOUR PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
CITED FOR CONTEMPT BY THE HOUSE.
NOT ONE OF THEM WAS EVER
PROSECUTED CRIMINALLY, AND THAT
GOES ACROSS THE BOARD IN
DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATIONS.
ERIC HOLDER, LOIS LERNER,
HARRIET MIERS, JOSH BOLTEN.
THE IDEA THIS IS A CRIME IS
ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS.
THE HOUSE HAD AN ALTERNATIVE.
THEY COULD HAVE MOVED FOR CIVIL
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS A DISCOVERY DISPUTE THAT
COMES UP IN CASES.
IF YOU BELIEVE THERE IS A
PRIVILEGE, YOU MUST WITHHOLD.
MR. BANNON'S LAWYER ADVISED THE
COMMITTEE --
>> TO BE CLEAR, DAVID, ARE YOU
COMPARING -- ARE YOU COMPARING
YOUR CLIENT TO PEOPLE WHO WORKED
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IN THOSE
CASES?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, ACCORDING
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
THEMSELVES, IN THE OFFICE OF
LEGAL COUNSEL OPINION, THE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE APPLIES TO
FORMER EXECUTIVE DEPARTMENT
OFFICERS AND THE REASON FOR THAT
IS OBVIOUS.
>> ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
2009 OBAMA ERA DECISION?
>> THERE ARE SEVERAL OLC --
>> ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
OBAMA ERA ONE OR THE -- I WANT
TO BE CLEAR -- ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT THE OBAMA ERA ONE OR BUSH
ERA.
YOU SAID OBAMA ERA.
>> THERE ARE SEVERAL THAT MAKE
THIS POINT.
OBAMA ERA, THE ONE -- THE ERIC
HOLDER DECISION, BUT -- IN 2009.
>> THAT DOESN'T MAKE THE POINT.
IT SAYS THE CURRENT PRESIDENT
PREVAILS ON EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
YOU'RE VERY CLEAR, I'M SURE, ON
WHERE PRESIDENT BIDEN IS.
>> THAT'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
ISSUE.
YOU'RE MIXING APPLES AND
ORANGES.
THE QUESTION -- THE FIRST
QUESTION IS WHETHER EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE CAN BE INVOKED WITH
RESPECT TO A CONVERSATION WITH A
PERSON NO LONGER IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THE ANSWER TO THAT ACCORDING TO
THE OLC IS YES.
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT OFTEN
RELIES ON PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
IN THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
ADVICE.
WE WANT THOSE PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO SPEAK FREELY.
THAT'S QUESTION ONE.
QUESTION OF WHO PREVAILS BETWEEN
THE CURRENT OFFICE HOLDER AND A
FORMER PRESIDENT WITH RESPECT TO
THE PRIVILEGE IS A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT QUESTION.
BUT, OF COURSE, IN NIXON VERSUS
GENERAL SERVICES ADMINISTRATION,
THEY SAID THE FORMER PRESIDENT
ALSO HOLDS THE PRIVILEGE.
IT IS THE INSTITUTIONAL
PRIVILEGE SO IMPORTANT HERE.
BECAUSE WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK FREELY WITH AN
EXECUTIVE ON MATTERS OF
STRATEGY, SECURITY AND
OTHERWISE.
BUT, AGAIN --
>> AGAIN, I MEAN, AGAIN, ON
THAT, U.S. V. NIXON ESTABLISHED
A PRESIDENT HAS LEGAL DUTY TO
PROVIDE EVIDENCE TO A
PRESIDENT -- A SITTING PRESIDENT
HAS A DUTY TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE
OF ONE'S COMMUNICATIONS WHEN
RELEVANT TO A CRIMINAL CASE.
>> YEAH, BUT -- BUT EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE IS A WELL KNOWN STATUS
AND THE MAZAR CASE, THE SUPREME
COURT EMPHASIZED THE SANCTITY OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
ONCE IT HAS BEEN INVOKED, GO TO
THE COURT AND HAVE THE COURT
DETERMINE HOW IT SHOULD BE
APPLIED.
THE HOUSE COULD HAVE GONE TO
COURT, HAD THE DISCOVERY DISPUTE
RESOLVED BY COURT AND MR.
BANNON'S LAWYER SAID TO THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE, IF A COURT
ORDERS ME TO COMPLY WITH THIS
AND SAYS PRIVILEGE DOESN'T
APPLY, I WILL COMPLY.
>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT, LOOK,
HE MAY HAVE SOME INTERESTING
ARGUMENTS TO MAKE WHEN IT COMES
TO EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
HE'S NOT FORMALLY INVOKED IT
WHEN IT COMES TO TESTIMONY
REGARDING THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE, TO BE VERY CLEAR ON
THAT.
BUT STEVE BANNON CANNOT INVOKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE WHEN IT IS A
CONVERSATION THAT HE IS HAVING
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT THE
PRESIDENT, WHO ARE NOT PART OF
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH, BERNIE
KERIK, RUDY GIULIANI.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY FAIR GAME.
WHY HASN'T HE COMPLIED.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHY YOU THINK --
>> THOSE ARE QUESTIONS HE
ANSWERED.
>> MR. BANNON --
>> THAT'S NOT PROTECTED BY
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
>> THERE ARE CERTAINLY
CONVERSATIONS, IF MR. -- IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, CLEARLY THOSE
ARE NOT COVERED BY EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
THE CENTRAL ISSUE HERE IS THE
INVOCATION OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
THAT'S WHERE EVERYTHING FELL
APART WITH RESPECT TO -- THAT'S
WITH RESPECT TO THE CHARGES
HERE, NOT APPEARING AND NOT
PRODUCING THE DOCUMENTS.
>> PART OF HIS CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS CHARGE IS BECAUSE
THOSE -- THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
CLEAR, AND YOU KNOW THIS, DAVID,
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR THAT
SOME OF WHAT THEY WANT TO ASK
HIM ABOUT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
CONVERSATIONS THAT HE HAD WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
SO THOSE ARE QUESTIONS THAT HE
COULD JUST BY YOUR ADMISSION
THERE ANSWER.
HE HAS CHOSEN NOT TO, WHICH IS
WHAT LEADS TO THE CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS CHARGE.
>> HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THIS COMES UP REGULARLY WHEN
PRIVILEGE IS AT ISSUE IN
DEPOSITIONS.
HERE, MR. BANNON -- THERE COULD
BE QUESTIONS ASKED THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH PRIVILEGED AREAS AND NOT
PRIVILEGED AREAS.
IF HE SHOWED UP AND STARTED
ASKING QUESTIONS, PRIVILEGE
COULD BE VIOLATED.
ALL HE ASKED WAS IF HE WERE TO
SHOW UP, COULD A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE PURPORTED PRIVILEGE
HOLDER BE PRESENT TO INVOKE
PRIVILEGE ON A QUESTION BY
QUESTION BASIS.
HE WAS TOLD THE COMMITTEE RULES
DO NOT PERMIT THAT, AND SO HE
WASN'T ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
SO YOU CAN'T JUST SHOW UP AND
THEN TAKE A CHANCE THAT
PRIVILEGE THINGS COULD COME UP
BUT THE PRIVILEGE HOLDER CAN'T
BE THERE AND SIMPLY UNFAIR.
LOOK, PART OF THAT REFLECTS ON
THE COMMITTEE.
HOW CAN YOU POSSIBLY CALL AN
INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE WHEN THE
CHAIRMAN APPOINTED TO THE
COMMITTEE IS SOMEONE WHO SUED
PRESIDENT TRUMP PERSONALLY,
ALREADY DECIDED AND PUT IN
DOCUMENTS THE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
JANUARY 6th --
>> DAVID, PLEASE, LET'S FOCUS.
PLEASE, LET'S FOCUS.
>> LET'S FOCUS.
IT IS RELEVANT.
>> IF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT
ANY CONVERSATION THAT HE HAD
WITH THE PRESIDENT IS SOMETHING
THAT HE WANTED TO INVOKE
PRIVILEGE ON, EVEN THOUGH TO BE
CLEAR THE PRESIDENT HAS NOT
FORMALLY INVOKED IT, STEVE
BANNON COULD ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT A MYRIAD OF CONVERSATIONS
THAT HE HAS HAD THAT DID NOT
INVOLVE THE PRESIDENT.
THAT IS JUST A FACT.
AND IT SOUNDS LOOK A COPOUT WHEN
YOU'RE SAYING THERE COULD BE
SOME THAT ARE PROTECTED.
>> THAT'S NOT AN OH, BUT.
FOR ANY PERSON WHO DOES ANY KIND
OF LITIGATION, ONE WOULD NEVER
HEAD INTO A DEPOSITION WHERE
PRIVILEGE IS CLAIMED AND HAVE
THE CLIENT TAKE A CHANCE, OH,
WELL, MAYBE SOME OF THE QUESTION
WILL BE PRIVILEGED, MAYBE THEY
WON'T.
BUT THE PRIVILEGE HOLDER WON'T
THERE BE TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO OBJECT.
IT IS THE PRIVILEGE HOLDER WHO
NEEDS TO DETERMINE WHETHER HE
NEEDS TO MAKE AN OBJECTION AND
RESOLVED IN A COURT.
THIS OUGHT TO BE A CIVIL MATTER
RESOLVED IN A COURT AND MR.
BANNON'S LAWYER VERY RESPONSIBLY
TOLD THE COMMITTEE IF A COURT
ORDERS HIM TO ANSWER ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS, HE WILL ANSWER THEM
AND COMPLY.
THAT'S ALL.
LET A COURT DECIDE.
DON'T CHARGE SOMEONE CRIMINALLY.
DON'T POLITICIZE THE CRIMINAL
PROCESS.
THEY SAID FROM THE START,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RESPONSIBLE,
CHAIRMAN THOMPSON SAID HE
PERSONALLY SUFFERED DAMAGES, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE A FAIR
AND OPEN MINDED INVESTIGATION IN